[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voir les enfants bon choix
j'ai l'impression que nos petits amis
sont bien agitée à ta place mon cher
nounours je ne serai pas très tranquille
le patron je n'ai peur de rien moi n'y a
que les phares ce que je n'aime pas mais
à moi le nounours on ne m'en fais jamais
méfie toi quand même de nos foyers sans
crainte patron j'ouvre lol bon les
jeunes et la pop au papa nous voilà qui
parle de moi
on attendait avec 4 science tu sais les
approches tout va bien on t'a préparé
une belle surprise
va te faire tellement plaisir ce qu'ils
sont gentils ce soir regarde chrono
north ces temps de chasse nature du lieu
où mon coeur
ce pour moi bien sûr nous et tu peux
tourner tout moche but et tu n'as pas
besoin de partager avec les marchandes
faible donnez moi une cuillère s'il vous
plaît c'est plus convenable kilomètres
au nord mais moi j'ai pas trop vite
quitte rendrait malade je sais me tenir
durant une serviette pour essuyer la
bouche car tu baves regroupant des
besoins pas besoin là j'ouvre la boîte
vous me les a attrapés
mais je n'ai pas eu peur vous êtes de
petit diable je le dit aurait pu vous
voir un premier but pour moi fera chu
vous voulez rire ballon ou lis je vous
accompagne de droits de l'homme
tralala pourquoi quitter tralala 3 lolo
tour lolo
aux beaux ni tralala
bonne nuit les petits poissons d'avril
la jette à la 1h07 pour
des menaces venues nicolas bonnieu
preneur dont pierre bonne nuit les
enfants
j'espère que vous vous êtes bien amusé
aujourd'hui et que vous avez fait de
nombreuses farces
c'est tellement amusant le 1er avril
alors nounours qui content de toi lui le
dernier mot patron nicolas et
pimprenelle mon jouer un tour mais moi
je leur en ai joué un meilleur allons en
route mon bon le nours
bonne nuit les enfants faites de beaux
rêves
[Musique]
où
or